as an organization we wanted them to
know we support them
from the top down michael has called me
multiple times
to talk through things how can we help
how can we do different things
what resources can we do to our players
um you know to help them whether it's
community relations working on projects
they want to work on pr how do they want
to
you know carve out a statement we want
to be there for them and we support them
through this time much too
uh you and the team discussed what the
anthem will look like on opening day of
the 2020 season
we have not um
obviously we're going to support our
guys they know that but there's so much
up in the air
right now as far as what the fall is
going to look like on any level that we
haven't touched on that
[Music]
look that's cliff kingsbury the
cardinals coach talking about supporting
their guys without really making the
kind of unconditional unequivocal
statement that i'm looking for from
teams hey look if a guy chooses to
protest during the anthem we encourage
them to do it we support them in their
choice we don't want to get in their way
at all we don't want to make them to
think they have to do things a different
way we're not going to try to convince
them of anything it's their decision we
encourage them to make their personal
decision we don't encourage them to
kneel we encourage them to make their
decision i want to hear the team say
that because i think a lot of times i'm
not saying the cardinals are doing that
a lot of times yeah we support our guys
but then that kind of melts into
you know a team decision that everyone's
going to stand or something yeah right
so right we'll see as we get closer to
september chris but you know a lot of
these owners lean right a lot of these
owners are concerned about fan reaction
from those who would say thou shalt
stand
uh and uh it's gonna take a lot for them
to to to set that aside and say what
needs to be said we encourage players to
make their own personal conscientious
decision about what they do during the
anthem or whatever they do is fine with
us that's what every team needs to say
we'll see if they say it no doubt and i
think kingsbury will say that i think
he's you know he's fighting for the
greater good and he understands that
certainly i think it's one of those
things where he probably just caught him
off guard a little bit as far as what
they're going to do during the year
because like he's saying he doesn't know
what the hell is going to happen for the
football season at this point yet but
you better support him no matter what
your team is i don't know you know it's
the right thing to do at this moment
yeah african americans the black
community they need our help and of
course this the message didn't get
through the first time he also was a guy
on his team in deandre hopkins who came
from houston and let's not forget there
was some issues there you know as far as
a little racial tension and all that
that upset the players in that locker
room so you don't want to start that
problem again uh certainly but i think
kingsbury will certainly get behind his
players when the time comes
cliff kingsbury isn't the issue the
issue is the top of the organization
because the coach wants to remain the
coach and definitely into the future
he's going to take his cues from the guy
who signs the paycheck michael bidwell
is the one who's going to have to set
the tone in arizona just like jerry
jones in dallas and every other owner
throughout the league what tone will
they set they are the ones who need to
add their voices to this and say we
encourage our players to do whatever
they believe they must do during the
national anthem if they choose to stand
stand if they choose to kneel kneel if
they choose to sit sit it is their
decision and we encourage them to make
that decision and we will not try to
influence them in any way shape or form
period that's what every owner needs to
say in my opinion
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports